joining me now is Alex Norris Shadow
Public Health Minister and MP for
Nottingham North uh welcome to you are
you bracing
yourselves yeah of course we we've known
throughout this pandemic that as
infection rates increased and so do
restrictions in order to control it so
is mystifying with with notum being at
the moment on the highest in England
that we've got no restrictions at all
and you know we're pushing the
government to trying do that the
earliest possible
opportunity how do you describe the the
situation at the moment what sort of
conditions are people living under how
do they feel about how this is all being
managed well people are worried um you
know you need to understand that we less
than two weeks ago we were below average
um in terms of the infection rate and
now we've shot up and we're we're top of
that that leaderboard in England so
people are quite surprised by that and a
bit concerned by it but what people are
really worried about is where where you
know where the guidance from the
government is where are the restrictions
now we understand that actually um it's
not venient for the government to
introduce restrictions because they want
to change the system and that's what
we've read in the newspapers and that
we'll get extra restrictions in midweek
when they introduce their new system so
notzi and people are being completely
left over the weekend because it's not
convenient time for the government
people think that's unacceptable I think
that's
unacceptable so you're saying that
there's been really no communication at
all and you're having to read about uh
what possibly might happen in the media
yeah we're learning a lot more I'm
afraid in the media both traditional
media and social media than we are from
the government itself we had an MP's
meeting with the minister and a number
of the the scientists yesterday but that
was a general conversation when we
mentioned Nottingham they just simply
said that no decisions have been made uh
there's been no engagement with us
otherwise as members of parliament the
local Council have barely been talked to
the leader of the council's desperate to
to um to talk to the government but they
don't seem able to do that it's just
another you know another aspect of the
chaotic Communications that have that
have dogged the government's approach to
this pandemic and it's why we're
struggling it's not inevitable that
we're here we're here because the
collapse also of the test and Trace
system so the government continued to
fail and we're not are going to have to
pick up the pieces so as well as
Ordinary People you're saying that that
leaders in notum haven't been consulted
in terms of planning or what might next
happen yeah there I understand there's
been no direct contact between the
government and the leader of the council
I know he's spoken to Public Health
England as you'd expect but no proper
contact we've seen a statement from the
government that says um that they
support what the council says when the
council says that actually tonight we we
want people to act like there's
restrictions already into not mixed
households so why in Earth are they
putting out press statements saying they
support uh our approach locally when
they're not actually formally willing to
do so and the real concern Jillian is
that you know Nazi in my opinion is the
best Night Out in the Country it's one
of a big part of our economy it's
something we're really proud of but what
we don't want to see tonight is people
on a Friday and Saturday night which be
normally very very busy nights people
going out and thinking they'll get one
last harrar in so you know it's really
that's that is the cost of the
government's delay of waiting till next
week so you know we want people to not
do that instead to to act now like these
restrictions are in place the government
in disagreement with your analysis of
their communication and they've insisted
that they have been working closely with
local leaders and local authorities
throughout the pandemic yeah I mean they
can they say these things but it doesn't
make them true if you look what Mar
Manchester Andy Burnham said uh
yesterday about the complete lack of of
conversation if you look like week what
Nick Forbes the leader in Newcastle said
and if you talk to David melon the
leader of notam city council you'd say
that that is not the case so the problem
with the government is they spend a lot
of their Communications time trying to
justify the approaches that they've
taken and trying to tell everybody how
well they're doing if they actually
spent their time talking to people
locally and giving clearer
Communications more generally to the
rest of the population they'd be doing
much better but at the moment they're
just so defensive so you know that needs
to change and I think we're a really
good example of that we've had the mayor
of middlesburg refusing to accept a
local lockdown last week saying his town
would defy it um would you support local
leaders not adhering to to Future
restrictions no I think you'll see that
sort of thing if local leaders don't
feel consulted because I understand he's
changed his position slightly on that
now I think that's that's what happens
when people you know leaders in a
community feel that these restrictions
are done to them rather than done with
them I don't think that should ever be
the case I don't you know obviously
legally they wouldn't in a position to
defy it certainly not what I would want
in Notting him but what I want is that
for our local leaders to be talked to in
a timely matter manner they know our
community let's get them around the
table let's agree what's best for an
area and then let's just get it done
instead what we've got is delay
dithering and complete lack of clarity
and that's putting the health of people
in my community at risk Alex Norris
Shadow Public Health Minister and MP for
notingham north thank you very much for
speaking to us